according to a new poll many Americans
seem stunned by the president's lack of
action overseas as American troops are
targeted now almost Daily Now recently
the US Navy they did sink three little
baby hooti Rebel speedboats in the Red
Sea after coming under attack but so far
the commander-in-chief has done little
to counter this aggression now Iran they
are sending a warship to the region and
meanwhile just a few weeks after their
meeting in California well China's
dictator once again threatened what he
calls reunification of Taiwan we would
call that an invasion the Biden White
House doesn't seem to care we have war
in Europe that continues with no end in
sight now we're in the Middle East and
all my sources tell me Joe Biden is
saying one thing publicly about Israel
and very different things privately here
with analysis Fox News contributor
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
you know Mr secretary I look at the
world situation I don't care if it's
Europe Ukraine Russia I I look at this
new axis of Evil China Russia Iran as
probably the biggest threat since the
Cold War and I think they're more
emboldened than ever just based on their
actions what are you
seeing Sean first of all happy New Year
I think your analysis is exactly right
um what we saw happen on October 7th
what we saw happen in Afghanistan where
13 Americans killed the Chinese spal
these these things are all connected by
dictators authoritarian regimes that do
not fear the United States of America
that that President Biden has allowed
such an accelerated rate of decay of our
deterr that we had built up in the four
years that President Trump and I were
serving uh has really done the American
people disservice and it is dangerous
it's dangerous not only for the Israelis
and for folks in the Middle East but
it's dangerous for folks here in the
United States of America as well a wide
openen Southern border and a North
Korean leader a Chinese leader a Russian
leader who don't think that the United
States will stand up and defend its most
sacred values is a place that is a very
dangerous country here at home as well
so so when President she just recently
spoke in the last week or so about
reunification with Taiwan that to me he
said it before but this time it feels
more real feels more real to me because
uh if in fact that is his geopolitical
ambition
or it's going to happen while Biden's
president that means he got he has at
least they have in their mind about a
year to get it done I predict that's
probably going to happen I hope I'm
wrong but I think I'm going to be proven
right
sha I hope you're wrong too and it's not
a independent variable we we have the
capacity to deter xingping to
demonstrate our resolve to show that we
just just as we'll provide all the
ammunition weapons missiles that the
Israelis need to defend their Homeland
just as we should be briding what the
ukrainians have asked for to defend
their Homeland from The Invasion by
Vladimir Putin we need to make clear
that we're not going to allow Shing ping
to steal our property here at home we're
not going to allow to run spy rings and
spy balloons against the United States
on our own soil and we're not going to
let him take over an independent and
free Taiwan by force in the Pacific
it'll be a very very dangerous thing for
all of us whether that's the Hawaiian
Islands Alaska Guam all all of these
places when you pick up the map and see
what he's doing in Taiwan make no
mistake about it shishin Ping's
intentions aren't limited to what he
calls the reunification you properly
described as the Takeover of Taiwan what
do you make of the advancement of the
Iranian nuclear program
and they're sending a warship uh to
basically seemingly help out the hoodie
Rebels and they've been using those
Rebels to fight a proxy war against
Saudi Arabia um and they're even the
hoodi rebels are firing missiles uh into
Israel also so that's another front in
the Israeli conflict um you know is that
not a bold move by the Iranians to send
that warship
there Sean remember the the history of
this Administration and the Obama
administ ation with Iran they they have
they have emboldened the Iranian regime
they've provided them $6 billion in
exchange for six American hostages there
are now more Americans held by the
Iranians after that than there were
before we released that $6 billion no
this is all Iranian driven uh the
Israelis have at least a three front
maybe as many as a five front War
underway today it's not something that's
in the future or might happen if there's
an escalation if we don't impose real
costs on the Iranian regime we're coming
up on the fourth anniversary of when we
took out suani it's January 3rd if we
don't impose real costs on the Iranian
regime if we just keep taking out
dingies and firing at uh empty
warehouses in Syria the Iranians will
feel emboldened empowered and they will
not only continue to attack Israel but
they'll attack Middle Eastern countries
and I fear that they will do things here
in the Homeland as well do you ever
think you'd see this much anti-Semitism
in the halls of Congress on College
universities uh you know just in the
past week at the sight of the World
Trade Center where 91101 we lost you
know two that day we lost
2,977 Americans and they were actually
shouting Allahu abbar uh Australia you
had protesters shouting gas the Jews you
see uh anti-Semitism rampant all across
Europe um it's it's beyond disturbing to
me how do you analyze
it yeah know I never I never thought I'd
see this volume and this depth of
activity and then I never thought I'd
see our Central inst institions whether
that's the United Nations or our
universities so fail to understand this
is black and white this is good versus
evil to allow this anti-Semitism to run
rampant and then not to do anything
about it is morally morally indecent and
I I never thought I'd see that shanan I
regret it I hope that America can get
find its way back I'm confident that we
will but it's going to take real
American leadership not just from
presidents of the United States but from
each of us all across the country making
clear this is just
unacceptable yeah we do need people like
you we do need adults like you back in
charge I hope you're not busy in about a
year or so I think uh I think there's a
big job waiting for you somewhere uh
secretary Pompeo happy New Year sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else